[Music]
but where does the time go it is now
time for the final exam where we see
which news professionals and they are
and contributors have been paying
attention to current events tonight we
close the 2017 edition with a special
Year in Review our questions just won't
span this past week all of 2017 is on
the table
this week's contestants are really
bright CEO Fox News contributor Lisa
Booth playing herself as Lisa booth and
Mark Steyn who once hosted the show
earlier in the week you guys ready yeah
I just want to say I try to get you to
pool Donna Brazile this morning on Fox &
Friends and you wouldn't do it
you know I Lisa they don't give me the
questions ahead of time because I know
I'd break meanwhile our contestants have
buzzers and they have their hands on the
budgets that's all I can ask you to do
I'm going to ask them questions just to
review the rules and the first one to
buzz in gets to answer you must wait
until I finish the question before it's
out like family feud until they do it if
you get it wrong it's not okay
you lose a point if you get it right you
get a point yeah and the best of these
five questions gets gets winnings we
don't get any yeah like you did I mean
when you again shannon bream the ref
should have stopped that fight and
scrape what was left of you off the
canvas so as long as we don't know if
the kilmeade scenario I thought if I did
the best I can it was okay
mark shannon bream all right let's go
I'm ready sorry Shannon you're off so
these guys are on here's the first
question
cast your mind back to the beginning of
the year we were children then there was
a big mess up at the Oscars with the
presenters for the best picture we've
got okay i'm gonna review the rules when
we finish the question with the picture
reading out the wrong winner which two
acting legends were left red-faced after
reading the wrong card
before you answer more Oh give me your
answer mark did you finish reading you
finish have you finished the question
Faye Dunaway and Warren Beatty let's
watch the most embarrassing mistakes
that were saying in the awards show
history everyone talking about it yeah
Warren Beatty Faye Dunaway Hollywood's
Bonnie and Clyde coming out there and
they robbed the Best Picture winner of
their title they read the wrong card
moonlight was in fact the real winner
turns out that the presenters were given
the wrong envelope by mistake you are
correct sir watch a word show I think
the excuses after getting it wrong make
it all the worse so he said all right
and thanks for almost getting it right
mark with by playing attention to the
road okay question number two now
President trumpet North Korean dictator
Kim Jong on shredding a lot of insults
this year
Kim called Trump a dotard among other
things and Trump unveiled his new
nickname for Kim on the floor of the
United Nations what is that
nickname Lisa booth Rocketman let's
watch it president Trump said the US may
have no choice but to quote totally
destroy North Korea and he called out
the dictator Kim jong-un
Rocketman is on a suicide mission for
himself and for his regime
Rocketman obviously the Elton John song
free I don't know why anyone in the
mainstream media is complaining because
he's calling like you said judges 1 1
correct the judges I get why by the way
just to review the score 1-1 we are tied
we move to question number three all
right mark and Lisa are still playing
themselves in this game that we are
indeed playing ourselves poorly Donald
Trump sent the mainstream media into a
complete meltdown this year which time
after tweeting that could be the most
famous typo of all time what was that
type of Fe is it coffe Fe watch if you
want me to say how to pronounce this
word I don't know none of us
none of us really know how to say this
thief
cough fe we're gonna let you make the
call this morning that's where it hit
the glitch Cove thief cough a thief II
that's a confess a because you speak
fluent French despite the constant
negative press efef a what are you here
this is Ben yeah you understand right
Lisa pulls ahead to one oh but it's a
typo that you're in Spicer says without
a type which is del made a mistake who's
in the sentence Mark Steyn I dare you
okay he could probably do it though he's
very smart very smart you'll figure
chemistry you two have a starting to bug
me okay question number four it's a
multiple choice question okay Hillary
Clinton embarked on the world's longest
book tour this year and she explained in
great detail all the things she has been
up to since losing the election she also
revealed that she's been drinking a lot
of alcohol to deal with the stress
what is Hillary's go-to drink of choice
is it a pina colada
be Bloody Mary or sea-shore neck mark
Stein Chardonnay Laser choice is it
shorten a go to the tape I want Y
Chardonnay helped a little too
yes I had my fair share of Chardonnay
so trying to calm myself down and you
know my share of Chardonnay it was a
very hard and let's go check the scores
now - - oh no buddy we've gotten the
right answer each and every time yeah so
this will be the tiebreaker if my math
is correct
Oh - it isn't all right let's go final
question back in the summer
ESPN faced a firestorm after it pulled
an announcer from calling it university
of virginia football game the reason
ESPN didn't like his name was the
announcers name Oh Robert Lee Robert Lee
Lisa booth says Robert Lee really judges
jot that down now I want to roll the
tape what a Fox News Alert there are
reports tonight that ESPN has pulled a
football announcer from the other coming
game because of his name which is Robert
Lee the twist Lee is an Asian man not
exactly your vision of an
unreconstructed confederate has defeated
mark Stein by a final score of three to
two for this moment believing me I just
want to thank my parents for believing
me right and believing you were smarter
than Mark is this like the Oscars did
you read out the wrong winner
no no the winner is Lisa congratulations
on the quick draw you may chatted Bream
proud wherever she ain't gonna beat me I
still consider you very bright and I
still consider myself the second worst
contestant thank you very much somehow
it always comes back
great job thanks so much that was your
final exam